Ansel I wanted to start with you because
one question that's been on my mind a
lot because someone else in the business
actually brought it up to me and he
wanted to hear more actors talk about it
is the idea of being a lead but part of
an ensemble and I know you share that
Duty with folks here but what is it like
having just icons like Nicole Kidman by
you but needing to be a leader in the
heart of this movie um I think that
films are very ensemble II and
especially the collaborative art it's no
I I don't think I was any sort of leader
john crowley is more likely like the
director but to work alongside nicole
kidman top it was maybe my favorite part
of the whole thing so it's really great
that but we make it not weird and I have
a iced cappuccino please
wait wait so my next question is going
to be the question that you guys are
gonna hear a million times over but I
kind of don't care because this is one
of my favorite aspects of the book -
it's just what the Goldfinch represents
since its history it fills a void in
someone's life and I feel like if you
have that object in your life it's so
important to you I know I have one so
what does your Goldfinch the silence is
making me think no one's asked you this
yet makes me happy no I have like I have
a number of gold finches that's right
here I put it my grandfather's tuxedo
mm-hmm I have a locket but I have things
that I yeah so but they're so deeply
personal it's actually probably the most
one of the most personal questions I've
ever been asked so that's because it is
your eyes what is the thing that
represents you know so but I definitely
have maybe yeah six or seven
like and then I've also had things taken
that that were my Goldfinch
which is just stolen which stolen yeah I
had a some watch that was taken that was
my great-grandfather's when we were
little and it was passed on through the
family and it was my mother's in and
then it was taken and those things are
like oh oh so there's a fear also in
connecting to an object for me about
that all the time like this every single
day just in case anything that comes to
mind I took up over there come on No
maybe maybe it's better off you're kind
of like you know free and not tied down
to a specific thing I'd love to be naked
I also I don't know this is terrible
transition but I have to ask about
working with Roger Deakins and also John
I mean between working with an icon like
Roger and then with the incredible
directors you've both worked with all
throughout your careers do you notice
any specific shared traits amongst the
greats you're working with Steven right
now said come on I Stephen and John are
very different I feel like everybody you
know people are there's a lot of
different kinds of directors and John is
more of a theater director who you then
went to phone so that makes them very
different than like John is will set you
up for you that for your scene and
really remind you of where you are as a
character and Steven can be a little
more technical and it's more about
making the movie Edgar Wright is very
similar to Steven and John is as
something different
John really wants you to you want to
make sure that you're feeling what your
character is feeling when you say
under sir in a way that Stephen wants
everyone have fun make a movie so it's
like it give me a little more fun
sometimes hanging out on the west side
says he is one of my favorite directors
of all time anything you've noticed over
the years a shared they're all so
different they require you have I come
in blank and I check I will adapt to
sometimes it's no rehearsal sometimes
it's six weeks of rehearsals sometimes
it's I want you to be the character
sometimes it's completely technical
other I mean it is so different and I've
had the opportunity to work with some of
the greatest directors of all time and
the one trait they share though is that
they're passionate deeply passionate
about the art form and that's what I
love because if the passion is there I
do believe that comes through and the
last thing I want is someone that's
doesn't complacent I don't think there's
much of it nobody greater than that
right yeah thank you guys so much for
your time